extranjero
[Música]
muy bien hola y bienvenidos a todos,
esta es la transmisión en vivo actinf número
47.0 es el 3 de agosto de 2022
bienvenidos al instituto de inferencia activa
somos un laboratorio e instituto participativo en línea
que se comunica aprendiendo
y practicando la inferencia activa aplicada
puede  encuéntrenos en algunos de los enlaces de
la diapositiva.
Este es un video grabado, archivado,
transcrito y publicado en vivo,
así que envíenos sus comentarios
para que podamos mejorar nuestro trabajo.
Todos los antecedentes y perspectivas son
bienvenidos y seguiremos la
etiqueta del video en vivo.  transmite
todas las actividades del instituto de inferencia activa
son participativas, así que
háganos saber si desea contribuir o
participar, diríjase a
activeinference.org y haga clic en los enlaces
para participar directamente y para obtener
más información.
y una aventura única en
47. Vamos a discutir y
yuxtaponer no un papel como de costumbre,
sino tener un enfoque de múltiples ojos abiertos.
hacia dos artículos en esta situación
vamos a aprender y
discutir
de manera yuxtapuesta dos artículos de
inferencia activa y abducción en 2021
por ati vaiko
pieteren y majid beni
también discutiremos una
cognición social dinámica activa y una
inferencia activa de ines  hippolyto y thomas
van también de 2021,
todos los videos tienen
puntos cero y, de lo contrario, son
introducciones a estas ideas y
contexto adicional, no una revisión,
evaluación o palabra final,
y
esperamos usar esta coloración
de rojo claro para el papel abductivo
y  un azul claro para los inactivos
dejando el espacio abierto para
que surjan nuevos colores y combinaciones que
demuestren algunas áreas de síntesis
y vamos a hablar en este punto cero
con algunas preguntas importantes y repasar nuestros
objetivos, así como leer entre esos
objetivos  que es un poco diferente
a muchas transmisiones en vivo
, luego
brindaremos información general sobre cada documento en
términos de los objetivos que afirma el roa  dmap y
el resumen
, luego pasaremos a una
sección de antecedentes en contexto
que incluirá mucha información
sobre la semiótica de la inacción, la lógica abductiva
, etc.
, luego pasaremos a una yuxtaposición de
los dos documentos
y tendremos una  mucho tiempo para
discutir con, con suerte, varios autores
en las
próximas discusiones.
una yuxtaposición inicial y una revisión
de estos documentos que, de nuevo,
emocionarán a alguien por leer los
documentos, sumergirse más profundamente y aportar
su propia perspectiva para influir en estos
temas tan interesantes,
así
que pasaremos a las
introducciones. Soy Daniel. Soy  un investigador en
california
y hablaré más sobre lo que es emocionante
en las próximas diapositivas se lo pasaré a
dean
eh buenos días mi nombre es dean estoy en
calgary y uh supongo que
tal vez  la mente retorcida que trató de
juntar esta idea y tal vez
cambiar un poco la forma en que vemos
la inferencia activa al tratar de extraer
dos documentos
diferentes de enfoques aparentemente aparentemente diferentes
y luego
ambos
incorporando el uso de
inferencias activas  como una metodología
para analizar situacionalmente y cuáles son
las implicaciones para eso,
así que lo encuentro realmente emocionante
y se lo pasaré a stephen,
así que gracias, decano, sí, stephen, aquí estoy,
en um, toronto, canadá, um,
y estoy  Realmente estoy
interesado en estos dos documentos
porque ambos hablan mucho de los
enfoques participativos en general y la idea de
cómo las personas se involucran en el mundo,
por lo que las preguntas en torno a la
inacción
son realmente relevantes, al igual que la
pieza de abducción.
Si bien ambos son documentos bastante diferentes
, ambos me
hablan
con mucha fuerza, así que eso es realmente
interesante, así que
espero poder
explorar eso.  Estoy trabajando con
uh Teatro participativo
Psicología comunitaria
Desarrollo comunitario y
procesos de desarrollo a múltiples escalas y estoy muy
emocionado
de ver cómo
esta toma científica
puede responder a
lo que podría llamarse una pregunta participativa basada en la práctica
que yo  he estado
mirando, así que se lo devolveré a
daniel
excelente, gracias a ambos y a dean, gracias de
nuevo por el viaje de muchos meses,
los muchos correos electrónicos, meses
y mensajes que hemos recorrido
porque espero que esto se
desarrolle e incluya en  una manera que
lleva las transmisiones en vivo
y el tipo de materiales en los que estamos
trabajando más allá de donde hemos
ido
y
en
espíritu de eso, pasaré al decano para
presentar algunas de las grandes preguntas aquí,
bueno,
si vas a sacar dos  documentos que
no
parecen tener mucho en común en términos de
su tema, tendrá
que abordarlos desde un ángulo un poco
diferente en términos de no solo
descubrir qué hay dentro de un documento sino
cómo se pueden comparar esos documentos, por
lo que reunimos algunas
preguntas en torno a la idea
de qué papel, como
herramienta de análisis situacional o
método de realidad, podría desempeñar la inferencia activa para
extraer cosas que parecen estar muy
lejos y separadas y enredarlas,
etc.  las preguntas eran básicamente: ¿puede
la inferencia activa ser tanto
algo que sostiene, contiene o
limita algo y también ser la cosa
limitada o agarrada? ¿Qué es la
inferencia activa o si y si el énfasis activo es que
la cosa
está contenida,
digamos una línea divisoria en una tabla
y  una celda
para que la brecha real en la que realmente podamos
poner más información sobre cómo se
ve, cómo se vería
como una restricción y un separador
simultáneamente y creo que es esa
pieza de reciprocidad que vamos a tratar
de desentrañar en  las próximas transmisiones en vivo
y lo que es similar o diferente
para controlar
los modelos y un proceso diferente que
es el modelado
gracias steven ¿quieres?  No, para agregar
algo aquí,
no, creo que
eso cubre mucho, lo único
que esa x que está allí es una especie de
denotación,
ya sabes, puede activar modelos de inferencia que
modelan
um marcos, por lo que esta
contextualización del término um
entra en escena.  jugar, pero hablaremos
de eso un poco más tarde, así que sí, gracias,
increíble, y
esta es
potencialmente una de las primeras diapositivas de nuestros objetivos
porque, con suerte, ayudará a
volver a este nivel.
El meme
aquí representa esta transmisión en vivo
reuniendo.
los dos periódicos de una manera en la que hemos tenido
una mano aplaudiendo
ahora vamos a unir eso en
dos ya puedes escuchar el sonido que sale de
la transmisión en vivo, especialmente si
estás escuchando a
dean, ¿qué describirías sobre r
ames?  o cómo
resumiría, oh, y otra nota que
agregaré sobre rna ames si queremos que sea
completo pero también que tenga videos
que se puedan escuchar y de una
duración temporal razonable para que haya muchas
diapositivas  es que tendrá una gran cantidad de texto
copiado del papel y simplemente hará una
pausa en el video si desea
leerlo, pero vamos a pasar
de muchas de las diapositivas de texto,
solo queríamos asegurarnos de que  todo el
texto estaba allí invisible, pero no
vamos a leer todo, así que
por favor, decano, resuma de qué
objetivos le gustaría
hablar, sabe, solo voy a
hablar sobre el tipo
de raíz de cada uno.  una de estas viñetas
que es echar un vistazo más de cerca al debate sobre el
instrumentalismo del instrumento del realismo
no tengo que entrar en qué
es eso si has participado en él
sabes lo que estamos describiendo
uh reforzar un enfoque de dos ojos abiertos
donde un ojo toma en el par de
papeles de inferencia activa
la condición social dinámica inactiva
y la abducción, mientras que el otro hombre, si el
otro ojo manifiesta inferencias activas
como un integrador de ambos
porque pensamos que en realidad puede hacer
eso sin mezclar,
en realidad puede causar una  tejido o un  trenza
y luego la tercera viñeta es hacer
explícita la necesidad absoluta si
vamos a hacer esas dos primeras cosas de
comprender la profundidad temporal de los
modelos que en realidad
incorporarían
dos artículos de temas aparentemente distantes a
medida que hacemos inferencias activas en
dos temas diferentes
y  luego, lo que hicimos fue extraer
cosas diferentes que los autores anotaron sobre
sus artículos.
conjunto de autores dice que usted
sabe realmente está analizando el
instrumentalismo
y sabe que sabe que es una
perspectiva científica válida, pero sabe
que existe, luego describe que conoce
esta pregunta sobre el camino hacia el
realismo
y el normalismo, así
que sabe dónde está
la idea de que en
un papel que el instrumentalismo es es
la forma de
capturar
o mantenernos bien en este
trabajo científico
que puede  ser desafiado um
y veríamos formas en que podríamos
necesitar aflojar eso cuando nos adentramos en
enfoques participativos, así que algo
intermedio que afloje ese
espacio científico y sea un espacio de práctica, así que lo
mismo con el segundo punto
um
donde está bien es  instrumentalismo
um, ya sabes el camino a seguir, entonces, ¿qué
constituye el
comportamiento cuando se vive en un nicho? ¿qué
constituye a los seres vivos?
um, y cómo resolvemos
qué camino a seguir.
usa esto
um si simplemente vivimos con ellos y
simplemente avanzamos
um o dónde deberíamos realmente
resaltarlos así que esto es de alguna manera tratando de pensar
en un um fuera de tal vez este tipo de
enfoque láser
en el
punto filosófico científico y diciendo está bien cuando
estamos tratando de llevar esto a un
contexto de equipo
, deberíamos aflojar algo de eso
, así que solo se menciona aquí para
dar una aplicación, deberíamos también
pensar en un  Acerca de
las impresiones activas precedidas o
sufijadas, ya sabes, influencia activa adaptativa,
influencia activa efectiva o
modelado de inferencia activa,
¿sabes qué tan importante es esa
aclaración para luego
pensar también en cómo se
podría utilizar la pieza de realismo instrumental de
estas otras maneras en las
que necesitamos posicionar?  um
, sabes completamente en uno completamente en otro
y si estamos en el medio
, sabes que
puede haber un mayor o menor acceso al
conocimiento según el contexto tan a menudo en el
trabajo participativo
diferentes tipos de prácticas sabes que
el contexto es clave
y luego este tipo  de habla un
poco de mi propia idea del trabajo co-
creativo y sé que, um
, sabes que daniel se relaciona mucho con los equipos
y los
decanos con la transformación
sabes que a menudo hay una pieza de co-creación
hay un poco en el que tú
quieres sostener la mariposa
sin aplastarla, hay algo
bastante delicado allí,
así que, ¿cómo podemos
llevar esto a veces a espacios donde es un
c?  o-espacio creativo, sabes dónde está
sucediendo el modelado de una manera contextual más sutil
y,
si bien tenemos estas
definiciones científicas y
diseños estratégicos y análisis rigurosos
y son útiles, no queremos que
aplasten lo que está sucediendo
y hay un par de  hay imágenes
que
hablan de eso y se lo pasaré
a dean tal vez y usted puede hablar sobre
el muestreo
de aguas en el medio y la mente la
brecha
bueno, creo que
esa fue una explicación hermosa y
pienso
cuándo si y  cuando los autores puedan
entrar, será algo a lo que
ahora podremos ponerle color.
Creo que hemos puesto algunas anclas en el
suelo, pero no hemos dicho
cuánto fluirá
puede ir entre esos nodos diferentes y
eso es lo que creo que queríamos
establecer aquí es la intermediación
muchas veces
como dice cuidado con la brecha que es
lo único que puede matarte en el
metro porque no estás prestando
atención a  el ga  p y creo que el
muestreo de las aguas intermedias hace
lo mismo, excepto que proporciona una
diferencia
sutil un poco diferente en términos de la
fluidez de ese tipo de espacios, por lo que
creo que sería realmente interesante
si lo usamos como nuestro portal.  sobre cómo
podríamos unir las cosas y
hacerlas
bailar cuando, de lo contrario, estarían
sentadas en sillas en el lado opuesto
de la habitación, podría ser una
conversación interesante para comenzar en el punto uno y
dos,
gracias a ambos y el único comentario lo haré.
agregue aquí está
esta discusión que hemos tenido sobre los
adjetivos que preceden a
la inferencia activa adaptativa afectiva, etc.
y luego también stephen el enfoque que ha
llevado al sufijo que x y
corchetes
modelo de inferencia activa como una instancia
o caso o realización
inferencia activa  marco
teoría del proceso de inferencia activa lo que
sigue y esto realmente me recuerda las cláusulas de
bifurcación izquierda y bifurcación derecha
en gramática y sintaxis
y que hay una base c  lause,
¿cuál es nuestra cláusula base y luego qué
ramificaciones antes, durante y después?
descripciones en los documentos antes de
retroceder a los antecedentes en contexto
y luego avanzar a los
documentos que analizan sus puntos principales,
por lo que no vamos a leer los resúmenes
,
por supuesto, ambos están disponibles para estos documentos
aquí está el resumen para
inferencia activa y abducción
aquí está el resumen de
cognición social dinámica inactiva e inferencia activa
aquí están las palabras clave para ambos
artículos el artículo inactivo
tiene las palabras clave construcción de nicho de cognición social
inferencia activa teoría de la mente y
activismo y teoría de sistemas dinámicos
el artículo de abducción tiene la  palabras clave
abducción inferencia activa energía libre
principio primero y manta
relaciones triádicas y perforar
Vayamos a los objetivos
y las afirmaciones
del artículo sobre abducción,
así que,
decano, ¿le gustaría cubrir
alguno de los objetivos del artículo sobre abducción?
Lo que me gustaría hacer es
predecir a qué
aspiran ambos artículos y
eso  es que verá una palabra clave en la
segunda viñeta de este que es
alianza y luego hay palabras
que verá en el otro documento
donde nuevamente dicen
que queremos que las cosas se unan
pero queremos  tenga cuidado con la forma en que
describimos esa unión, no
queremos que se perciba
metafóricamente como una combinación o una anulación de
dos o más cosas que creemos que
tienen una relación asociativa,
um, así que creo que cuando
estás pasando por el  los objetivos de los dos
documentos si retrocede un
poco, verá que los autores
de ambos documentos
están dando una explicación dura sobre a qué
relación quieren que prestemos atención y
eso es algo que ambos  los papeles
comparten que es un énfasis pesado  asis sobre la
relación
gran punto y ambos están
escritos de manera muy rica y poderosa
y aquí vemos alianza y lealtad
y ciertamente habrá
mucha discusión en ambos artículos sobre la
integración de
ontologías y conjuntos de vocabulario dispares o parcialmente relacionados
y diferentes pensadores diferentes hilos
del desarrollo intelectual,
estas citas del documento se pueden leer
y, por supuesto, se amplían en el
documento,
pero como dijo el decano, el enfoque de este documento está
en la alianza intelectual
entre la inferencia activa y el
principio de energía libre fep y principalmente el trabajo de
cs pierce
en términos de  semiótica pragmática
gramatismo lógica abductiva ese es el
objetivo la síntesis es reunir a esos
dos de una manera que sea sinérgica
y proporcione significado
para mirar
áreas que son realmente difíciles de
simular para computadoras um y
la forma en que ocurre la abducción, o
particularmente con los humanos, es
muy sofisticada y creo
que es realmente útil ver la
semiótica, que en realidad se usa mucho
en la
sonografía teatral y el diseño de escenarios,
um pragmatismo, así que se incorporó a esto con
una teoría.  eso es lo que sabes, trasciende la
ciencia, a menudo se usa en
otros campos, como
las ciencias naturales, tiene algún uso,
pero a menudo se usa en humanidades, así
que creo que
esto le está hablando a esa pieza sobre
qué es lo que
se revela ese tipo de salsa secreta.
ese tipo de golpe en el alma que
normalmente falta y en acción
también hay algo así como que las
increíbles
afirmaciones del artículo
están en todo el artículo, pero solo para
resaltar algunas de las afirmaciones clave
que afirman que tienen el objetivo que se
propusieron.  hacen
entre el trabajo de inferencia activa y
la abducción y
aparece la perspectiva semiótica están afirmando que eso es
factible y que están proporcionando una
primera  esbozarlo
en esta integración teórica teórica
de lo nuevo y lo viejo
algo rojo algo azul algo
nuevo algo viejo
y los dos marcos, lo nuevo y lo
viejo, respectivamente,
son las instancias modernas de la
neurociencia y la ciencia cognitiva
representadas por un principio de energía libre
y en el  antigua una interpretación históricamente exacta
y precisa de la inferencia abductiva,
incluida la importancia de
la economía de la investigación, todas las cosas a las que
vamos a regresar solo
quería aclarar las afirmaciones allí, ¿puedo
agregar una, sí, por favor,
muy rápido, así que integración teórica
allí?  Quiero decir, si puedes
pensar en cuando hablábamos de nuestros
objetivos,
ahora la pregunta es esto es lo que dicen los
autores,
lo que nos preguntamos es si eso hace
una inferencia activa tanto en el
producto de integración como en el integrador, el proceso
y nuevamente yo  quiero quiero
bromear un poco con ese paso porque creo
que va a volver a suceder cuando
miremos  en el otro
periódico usarán una nomenclatura diferente,
pero van a decir lo mismo y
nuevamente es difícil ver los puntos en común a
menos que usted y usted no tengan que
inventarlos, solo tienen que
notarlos en
el  dos tipos diferentes de bosques
y un punto sobre el hecho de que
ambos usan la inferencia activa
como un integrador y un
diferenciador. Estamos creando un
modelo integrado de estados internos y
externos y generales
al diferenciarlos y luego, por
supuesto, la integración.  y la diferenciación
también tienen un
uso conjunto en matemáticas con la
notación integral y la derivada, por lo
que habrá muchas cosas que se
unirán, um,
steven todavía tiene las manos levantadas, sí, por favor,
solo una cosa también, creo que
es realmente útil hablar de esto.
neurociencia en esta
neurociencia computacional y resaltar eso
porque creo
que algo que
es la realidad en el mundo allá afuera
la cultura allá
donde están estas ideas  lo que circula es
que la
neurociencia se pone patas arriba básicamente por
la influencia activa de la
neurociencia como campo,
tal como la gente lo entiende,
es
una especie de
proceso deductivo de cosas que entran y luego
se evalúan y
concretan en oposición a este
viaje predictivo, así que creo que es
realmente muy útil
porque esto es algo
que todos enfrentamos y creo que lo que también
noté cuando hablé con algunos
neurocientíficos es que en realidad
tuvieron una crisis existencial y cambiaron en
parte a menudo al presentar
afirmaciones inactivas y ver realmente si  las
afirmaciones inactivas están ahí, ¿cómo puede mantenerse tan unido su trabajo con la
neurociencia?
Así que
hay esto, hay una parte
aquí que se relaciona con lo general y
esa parte general
es más importante
cuando comenzamos a traer
una influencia activa de
las áreas especializadas.  donde está como
enclavado y se conocen sus reglas del juego
y estás en las áreas donde la
gente dice bien neurociencia  sé lo
que eso significa
y listo, así que muchas gracias, gracias,
el artículo tiene relativamente pocas
secciones, tiene una
introducción, luego presenta
un emparejamiento
de inferencia activa a la luz de la
abducción
abducción a la luz de la inferencia activa
referencia ligeramente oblicua a nada en
la biología tiene sentido excepto a la luz
de la evolución o excepto a la luz de
algo y estas son dos luces de
regreso a esas islas cuál es el espacio
entre
y luego hay una discusión
sobre la economía de la investigación y su
naturalización de energía libre y la conclusión
y el  perforar las madrigueras de los conejos son profundas
, vamos a entrar en algunas pronto
en el artículo inactivo,
así que aquí vamos a describir las
afirmaciones de Ames y la hoja de ruta del artículo de inferencia
activa y cognición social dinámica inactiva,
el artículo presenta un artículo de dos  El primer
objetivo es diseccionar nuevos relatos
que mezclen el activismo con
relatos inferenciales y explicar por qué hacerlo
implica una contradicción.
El objetivo principal es ofrecer
la única vinculación de cuentas razonable en el
activismo y las cuentas inferenciales,
especialmente en este caso de cognición social,
así que
sí, por favor, no, adivine lo que esperaba. ¿
Podría ahora convertir la palabra vinculación en
púrpura para
nosotros?  describiendo el
medio que Stephen hizo un trabajo encantador
al enfatizar antes de que realmente
comenzáramos a mirar
los documentos en sí,
sí, está en el medio,
sí, es increíble y en realidad es a
través de su solicitud y la
plataforma de diapositivas se convierte en un
estigma social dinámico activo
y así
esa es una prueba de concepto de qué,
pero estos son los objetivos de este documento
, también tienen muchas afirmaciones
articuladas a lo largo de la discusión
y, de hecho, usan una notación muy clara
para describir las afirmaciones específicas
de otros trabajos y de su propio trabajo
y sobre qué afirmaciones.  e hipótesis
tienen qué relación lógica
um van a hacer afirmaciones sobre la
naturaleza de la cognición y su
van a discutir algunas de
las afirmaciones relacionadas con el nicho cognitivo social humano
y hablar sobre la importancia de la construcción del
nicho de enculturación de relaciones
y luego hablarán
sobre la teoría de la mente tom
y sobre la compatibilidad o las
contradicciones.
asociado con la vinculación de
afirmaciones inactivas con la
teoría de la mente o explicaciones inferenciales
la hoja de ruta del documento
establece muchos de estos objetivos y
afirmaciones con bastante claridad comienzan con una
introducción
e introducen un trabajo
reciente aunque influyente en el
campo de la inferencia activa que es el
marco del pensamiento a través de otras mentes
ttom
y, como dicen, diseccionan este
relato
para tratar de separar la forma en que, en
su opinión,
se unieron los recuentos inactivos e inferenciales.
También tienen una figura que describe una
manta de markov que será un
concepto que jugará keely en ambos  de
sus artículos
sección 2 algo tiene que dar
rechazo inferencia inactiva t  a través de
otras
mentes, van a utilizar dos suposiciones, a
saber, que la cognición social se reduce a
la representación mental y dos, que
la cognición social está programada desde el nacimiento,
y no estarán de acuerdo
con estas dos suposiciones y en su
oposición a estas suposiciones
respaldadas por subafirmaciones.  y evidencia
que los llevará a sus
conclusiones más amplias
, usarán la
teoría de sistemas dinámicos
y hablarán sobre cómo
se puede vincular dst con un activismo en términos
de su compatibilidad y qué se
ofrecen estos dos marcos dentro de una
lectura instrumentalista
y  luego van a discutir la
inferencia activa específicamente en el contexto de
la teoría de los sistemas dinámicos por un lado y la cognición inactiva y la
cognición social por el otro
lado, esa es la separación dinámica inactiva
que describirán con algunas cifras
sobre similitudes y diferencias
entre la inacción social en general  como
conceptualizados fuera de la
inferencia activa y luego son  vamos a
presentar visualmente cómo la inferencia activa
enriquece esa imagen
y luego tienen una tabla muy interesante que
distingue entre los
fenómenos observados en el mundo natural
y el comportamiento observado en el mundo natural.
antecedentes en la
sección de contexto, por lo que en esta sección del punto
cero
vamos a
usar algunas citas del artículo con seguridad,
pero también vamos a dar un paso atrás
y demostrar solo la punta del
iceberg de la beca y la
investigación.  que llevamos a cabo antes de llegar
a este punto,
esperamos emocionar
al oyente o al lector
y brindar algo de contexto en estos
hilos muy profundos que se
abordarán y aproximarán en los
documentos. Proporcionaré una primera nota aquí o
decano, vaya a  Es
solo que creo que creo que este es un
momento espectacular para decir que
está bien, así que los
antecedentes y el contexto, así que estamos hablando,
tal vez,
del entorno temporal y
físico,
así que  Ahora es algo que podemos
analizar situacionalmente
y, de nuevo
, no importa si usa la
inferencia activa o si usa un
modelo de reparto o si usa
la programación de iniciativas profesionales. El resultado
final es que todos están tratando de
averiguar
cuál es la situación a
través de un análisis.  método y
me imagino que cada uno de esos
métodos
tiene una mayor o menor viabilidad
dependiendo de cuál sea la situación tanto
temporal como físicamente,
así que creo
que esas son las cosas críticas, no estamos
diciendo que cada uno de estos documentos
sea bueno o malo
estamos diciendo que cada uno de estos documentos
se centra en una
combinación de contexto de fondo diferente como mínimo
de dos, por lo que ahora, si juntamos las dos cosas,
no podemos
decir que va a ser lo mismo
que vamos a hacer.  pensar
en nuestros objetivos como personas que ahora han
mirado los dos documentos uno al lado del otro
que va a crear una entidad completamente nueva
gracias
por liderar este trasfondo y
contexto  sección de actualización quería
invocar a uno de mis poetas artesanales favoritos
william blake
y blake escribieron los
contrarios son positivos una negación
no es un contrario las
negaciones no son contrarios los contrarios
existen mutuamente
pero las negaciones existen no las
excepciones y las objeciones y las incredulidades
no existen ni se
organizarán jamás  Forever y ever
end citar los
contrarios en este
marco lógico cuádruple de blakeyan,
de hecho,
son parte de una dialéctica y existen
como una función de cada uno como convexo
y cóncavo o como la gravedad y la
radiación hacia la que Buckminster Fuller podría
llevarlo
y, por lo tanto, las negaciones en este poético.
marco
son aquellos que
no existen,
mientras que a y b pueden ser lo contrario,
mientras que a y no a tienen una
relación lógica diferente y este tipo de
enfoque lógico cuádruple
para reconocer el espacio de estado y las
afirmaciones de verdad que múltiples afirmaciones yuxtapuestas
pueden tener con
entre sí
también está previsto en muchas
tradiciones de conocimiento mundial
um fo  por ejemplo, el kata scotty
y esta es una
herramienta y un método lógicos que se han aplicado
durante mucho tiempo en las
tradiciones dhármicas del contexto indio
querían proporcionar eso y también
con estas imágenes que cualquiera de
ustedes puede explorar.
¿Aplaude con una mano o una persona que
hace las divisiones
tiene que ver con la contradicción y la
negación?
hay hay hay las
contradicciones se construyen si eso
tiene sentido
um y eso también se encarna y se promulga a lo
largo de nuestra vida por lo que bien podría ser
como un bebé sabemos que
la morfología del niño en
diferentes
etapas en diferentes contextos da las
formas
de
establecer situaciones
conciencia
y las contradicciones dentro de eso a medida que las
cosas se codifican, entonces tienes
estos estos
estos situacionales
um
los procesos son una especie de um son lo que estamos
haciendo en este flujo de modelado en curso el
tipo de campos de práctica
en estos diferentes artículos que los
sustentan el inactivista siente una práctica o
los um los campos de práctica más computacionales
que tienen son  lo que
encarnamos y nos metemos y aprendemos
y eso es lo que estamos
modelando intuitivamente de una manera que tenemos una
idea de cómo debemos modelar
en estas situaciones las contradicciones
pero ese modelado a
menudo y este es el peligro
cuando  es
dominado por alguien con su modelo,
es decir,
alguien en su mundo modelando
cómo es ser ellos mismos o tratando de
procesarlo, van y ven a un consejero
con su modelo y ese modelo
se está utilizando para adaptarlos al modelo
y luego ese consejero  nos dirá
cuál es su problema, cómo se enmarca, así
que creo que este modelo modelo en
um es
bastante relevante aquí porque sabes que
una vez que se establecen estas contradicciones,
bien podría ser que
haya un mo  del creado dentro de ese
dominio
y luego alguien que no está necesariamente
en ese dominio
puede atribuirse al modelo, no saben
cuál es el juego, no están en el
proceso y el modelo se hace cargo, por lo que
cambia a las divisiones.
porque entonces está bien, tenemos dos
cosas, están juntos
, estamos hablando de esto, sí, vamos
a abrirte y tienes una postura,
está bien, así que estoy un poco y en algún
momento es como si esa no fuera una postura, hermano,
eso es  esa es una división en la que te has metido
allí, vas a tener que tener cuidado,
así que te has metido en la idea de que
estás abriendo las cosas ahora si fueran
una cosa para empezar si fueran una
postura que se mantuvieron  de alguna manera se
han dividido de una manera en la
que ahora están
aislados el uno del otro,
supongo que estamos tratando de encontrar una
manera de no empujarlos a uno
ni separarlos, tal vez tener una
postura intermedia.
es um de alguna manera ágil y uh se
relaciona en este caso con el realismo y la
ins  trumentalismo que hace eco de algunos
temas más amplios.
aumenta mucho la probabilidad conjunta, por
ejemplo, por lo que la idea de división aquí
es realmente buena para
hablar metafóricamente porque
si está
mirando algo con
interferencia activa y está asumiendo que
en un experimento de laberinto de té tiene que ir bien a la
izquierda o a la derecha  los seres humanos
pueden ver una bifurcación en el camino y tomarla,
esa es una especie de broma permanente
si ves una bifurcación en mis piernas, tómalas
, no necesariamente
tienes que elegir un orbee, puedes
tomar todo y creo que eso es lo que
blake  está tratando de señalar con este
ejercicio y también es una contradicción
no, si veo un utensilio en el camino, puedo
tomarlo, pero si no estoy abierto
a la idea de que el tenedor no solo significa
izquierda o derecha,
entonces estoy  ya autolimitado en términos
de WH  Estoy probando lo que estoy
analizando situacionalmente,
gracias a ambos, de acuerdo con las
piezas de palabras clave más directas,
por lo que en acción desde el
sitio thisdefinitions.net, una acción es una de las
formas posibles de organizar el conocimiento y las
formas de interacción con el
conocimiento inactivo del mundo.  es el conocimiento que
surge a través de la acción y se construye
a partir de habilidades motoras, como manipular
objetos, andar en bicicleta o practicar un
deporte; esa es solo una de las muchas
definiciones que se han proporcionado
. También hemos tenido varias transmisiones en vivo y
debates en papel sobre una acción en inferencia activa.
por ejemplo,
en la transmisión en vivo activa número
seis, cuando en 2020 discutimos
ramstead en absoluto, una historia de dos densidades,
la inferencia activa es una inferencia activa
en
2021, discutimos un artículo también de
hippolyto, en el que se encarna una
actuación hábil donde está la acción
y, de manera interesante,
para  saging de alguna manera esta misma
discusión aquí hay una diapositiva de
esa transmisión en vivo um
con uh del papel hippolyto
y  aquí teníamos la
tríada penetrante uh y teníamos el simbolismo y
esto la semiótica y las referencias al
francés,
así que en realidad estábamos hablando del
concepto muy relacionado de representación
y, de hecho, aquellos que apoyan
y/o rechazan y/o encuentran contradicción
y vinculan todo el  arriba,
la discusión sobre el
inactivismo y el relato inferencial
va a depender mucho de la
cuestión de la representación y las representaciones cognitivas,
cuáles son, dónde o
si existen, y así sucesivamente,
um, eso fue una transmisión en vivo 23.
diseñar solo visualmente, vamos
a ver más representaciones pronto
en su opinión,
algunas de las distinciones entre
la cognición social tradicional
y la cognición social inactiva
y, por lo tanto, en lugar de solo una
interpretación visual del nombre de la imagen, considere
que le gustaría proporcionarlo.
abajo en el próximo, está bien,
así que aquí lo que veo es que en las
cuentas inferenciales cognitivas sociales tradicionales,
los engranajes  están girando dentro del cerebro
y luego hay bucles de acción de percepción
y vínculos que conectan
entidades sociales que están en su cuerpo, pero el
cuerpo se ve como una interfaz
para ese tipo de transferencia de información,
una postura extrema o una representación visual simple
y luego aquí en contraste nosotros  vea que
los engranajes están en todas partes, incluso en
el entorno en el nicho en el
espacio intermedio
y que sí, el cerebro está haciendo cosas,
pero también es parte de un sistema promulgado
que está implementando este
proceso cognitivo social enculturado un poco
más en un marco holístico para que  Dean, sí,
sí, solo iba a decir
en un minuto que vamos a ver de qué se
trata el tema de la abducción, pero por
ahora
me gustaría que la gente mantuviera
en su mente la idea de que
esto le está hablando a un tipo de  profundidad temporal,
pero esa profundidad temporal es
vertical,
creo que la abducción mirando
líneas de tiempo más largas durante cientos de años es más
horizontal, así que tenga en cuenta que
estamos hablando  rey profundidad temporal pero el
enfoque está en una profundidad temporal vertical o profunda en
lugar de una profundidad temporal lateral amplia
ambos importan pero son ortogonales
no significa que estén en conflicto
entre sí, solo significa que
van  en diferentes direcciones, eso es todo lo
que quiero
decir, es gracioso, izquierda y derecha u oeste y
este, esas son direcciones contrarias, pero
no son direcciones negativas,
y ahí es donde comenzamos a ver
cómo se otorga la ortogonalidad, la escasez
o la independencia condicional.
por una manta de markov, por ejemplo,
cómo se pueden ver en el marco
de los contrarios, aunque no de las negaciones,
stephen
y ese engranaje en el diagrama de la mano derecha
allí, el engranaje en el medio
, sabes que puede tener una profundidad temporal
que puede tener esta mente-cuerpo  la
pieza del entorno definitivamente está ahí como
dices y obviamente lo hace como una unidad de
análisis que es realmente desafiante
y también lo pondría allí como un engranaje, las
palabras se
contraen.  la brujería de nuestra caja de voz nos está dando
palabras en el espacio que nos rodea
para que sepa que también se están utilizando como herramientas
, así que de repente
estamos mucho más enredados, incluso si es
solo un discurso,
sí, y lleva tiempo que el discurso
viaje a través del  Internet y a través del
espacio y el tiempo
un poco más de profundidad en la inacción social.
Este recurso de investigación de la inacción
describe varios significados y sentidos de la
inacción
en los sentidos performativo y de producción,
así que lea
y también un artículo realmente bueno de 2009 sobre
semiótica cognitiva de de bruyne.  y de
haan
discuten algunas de las relaciones de un
activismo en la cognición social
e hicieron un excelente trabajo al
resumir lo que las
cuentas inferenciales e inactivistas pueden
unir y
discutir ese vínculo sí, por favor, decano,
sí, lo
leí porque lo encontré.  y
aquí hay algo interesante si
van a usar una metáfora de puente
creo que un activismo tiene un
puente es solo un puente vertical
es el  lado de un edificio que se está construyendo
y, por lo tanto,
no hay nada que no critique lo
que han escrito aquí, pero creo que
hay una deuda
y hay una capacidad de expansión, es
solo que se está volviendo
vertical, no va tradicionalmente de
lado a lado,
increíble,
así que  Profundicemos un poco en la
abducción y la semiótica,
bueno
, tuvimos un gran viaje de aprendizaje
juntos
y el
artículo
sobre la abducción con
uno o uno y medio o incluso dos de los
autores que eran verdaderos expertos en Pearson
siempre que muchos detalles
perforaran fue un escritor y pensador prolífico.
y colaborador y también gran parte del
trabajo no se publicó, lo que significa que
hay algunos sistemas de referencia arcanos
y no todo es
hiperaccesible, encontramos que el sitio commons.org es
inmensamente útil al proporcionar muchas
definiciones, así como enlaces a los
recursos que decano  te gusta
resumir cualquier cosa en esta página
nada más que
si te interesa el
pragmatismo y quieres superar a
william james en realidad william  james y
charles sanders pierce tenían un poco de
ellos fueron quizás hace 150 años
los primeros
conflictores sobre cómo funcionan las cosas
um en realidad es realmente es un
punto de partida increíble en términos de cómo las personas que
parecen estar en competencia entre
sí realmente hacen  unos a otros
más inteligentes pero, de hecho, muchas de las cosas,
muchas de las ideas que 150 años
después ahora estamos recordando,
tendríamos que decir que pueden sentir que
competían entre sí, pero creo que
lo que estaban haciendo era transmitir  o de
alguna manera construyendo un modelo mejor
porque no siempre miraban las cosas a
través de los mismos ojos, tenían ambos ojos
abiertos, así que solo diré que vayan al
sitio común, es realmente bueno,
sí, es genial, esta representación
irónicamente corta
apropiadamente  es del conocido
marco semiótico de la tríada de Pearson donde una
señal de pare se llama el representamen
la
instancia representada la señal de pare física la señal de pare real
el objeto es el desorden  los autos de edad deben parar
aquí y el interpretante es debería
parar aquí y ahí es donde obtenemos esa
entidad
agencia encontré un artículo interesante
sobre la interfaz de usuario
que trae algunas de estas
discusiones verdaderamente atemporales sobre semiótica y
lógica en un contexto digital
que están aplicando  esa semiosis a la
metáfora de la interfaz de usuario
podría imaginarse si fuera una
señal de alto en el mundo real o si fuera un
botón en un sitio web en un contexto de interfaz de usuario
y
cualquiera puede hacer una pausa y leer algunas de
estas excelentes selecciones de citas
y eh
Aquí se dieron muchas conferencias
sobre cómo
se vinculan los signos y símbolos de copias a
través de la lógica y la semiosis
, pero continuaremos
con la abducción específicamente, así que esto fue un
poco sobre la perforación y la definición
de la semiótica en oposición a
la ciencia de las cosas, las ciencias más positivas.
y la ciencia de las formas, que
son las ciencias más formales,
qué es el razonamiento abductivo,
esto fue muy fascinante de explorar,
esta es una cita de la abducción  En el artículo
que escribieron, es común en la
literatura secundaria,
por ejemplo, que se basa en perforar
para concebir la abducción como algo que ocurre en
dos partes o dos tipos:
abducción generativa y abducción selectiva.
Aquí hay otra perspectiva sobre los dos
tipos o las dos variedades o los dos
componentes. Motor de dos tiempos.  de
abducción de la enciclopedia de stanford
uh filosofía
que escribieron en la
literatura filosófica el término abducción se usa en
dos sentidos relacionados pero diferentes
en ambos sentidos el término se refiere al
razonamiento explicativo
en el primer sentido histórico se
refiere
al lugar del razonamiento explicativo en la
generación de hipótesis  eso es abducción generativa,
mientras que en el segundo sentido,
que es el sentido que se usa con más
frecuencia en la literatura moderna, se
refiere al lugar del
razonamiento explicativo para justificar o evaluar un
conjunto enumerado de hipótesis
y, en cierto sentido, hace que tenga sentido
el contenido.  tiene que ser generado para ser
curado las ideas tienen que ser específicas  ied
enumerados para ser justificados o
evaluados,
decano, continúe con esto
muy rápido, así
que ahora tenemos rojo y azul, lo cual fue
realmente muy importante para resaltar
que necesita ambos, necesita un mínimo de
dos para que la explicación
aparezca a
continuación. abductivo  el razonamiento en el
sentido probabilístico también se conoce como
inferencia a la mejor explicación es una
forma de razonamiento lógico que busca
la hipótesis más probable para explicar
algo un ejemplo los frijoles blancos
en la mano izquierda provienen de la bolsa de
objetos sostenidos en la derecha  mano aquí
podemos ver cómo la hipótesis presentada
depende de
una observación incompleta o una
inferencia, ¿hay frijoles también en la
bolsa e incluso si es así, esa es la fuente
de lo que se ha transferido a la
mano izquierda?  una situación,
qué tipo de antecedentes y qué
tipo de contexto
posees va a ir a esta cuarta forma
de lógica que o el bolso se ven literalmente
Pasé toda una vida
tratando de
desentrañar y luego
reformar en algún tipo de coherencia
y
aquellos que escuchan pueden comenzar a ver
indicios de observaciones sensoriales
anteriores Actualización posterior de creencias sobre el
mundo Incluso la selección de acciones entrando en
juego, especialmente la traducción de las disponibilidades de
acción instantánea de las posibilidades
en  políticas que pueden
ser evaluadas por su energía libre esperada,
pero vamos a llegar allí,
pasemos
a la abducción y aquí hay algunos de los
documentos más fascinantes disponibles sobre
bienes comunes relacionados con la abducción, muchos de ellos
y para continuar con uno de
los  recursos de bienes comunes sobre la
abducción como inferencia práctica
por thomas capitan
este trabajo del
que no vamos a leer
todo aborda muchos puntos interesantes
sobre la naturaleza dual de la abducción
con la generación de
hipótesis y la selección de hipótesis
y distingue que la
selección de hipótesis
puede hacer deductivamente  evaluaciones válidas
sin embargo la creatividad phas  e es
no inferencial que tiene mucha
resonancia con ideas como no censurar previamente
y tener una
discusión inclusiva al hacer una lluvia de ideas
y reconocer que tiene que haber una
selección en un período finito de espacio
y tiempo,
además hay una discusión
aquí
esto fue
relacionándonos
a medida que retrocedemos o nos entrelazamos
con el principio de energía libre la
conciencia inicial de la hipótesis
llega con la observación de un
todo cologado por medio de una
visión incontrolada del mundo de las
ideas en lo que él llamó la terceridad tal como se
da en la percepción
la novela que concibe cualquier  instancia de la
premisa 2
citar una parte anterior del trabajo es
causada por cogniciones previas
su contenido es sugerido por los hechos
observaciones observaciones sensoriales
pero no todo lo sugerido se infiere
de la cognición de los hechos
y, por lo tanto,
perfora continúa describiendo que hay
operaciones del  mente que son
lógicamente exactamente análogas a las
inferencias que
aceptan solo que son unc  consciente
y, por lo tanto, incontrolable y,
por lo tanto, no sujeto a críticas, por lo que,
dejando de lado preguntas como si
los procesos inconscientes podrían
considerarse controlables,
aquí vemos mucho indicios de
percepción como inferencia inconsciente y
también vemos continuidad
entre procesos de atención y
conciencia,
inferencias conscientes
y otras inferencias subconscientes.  y así,
de alguna manera, esto también proporciona un
marco integrado de percepción,
aprendizaje, creencia, actualización de la profundidad temporal,
conciencia consciente e inconsciente.
Todas estas características se exploran en el
trabajo persa y el
documento sobre abducción resaltará muy específicamente
ese hecho,
está bien, continúe un poco.  Un poco más de
abducción y retroducción.
¿Le gustaría agregar algo sobre
este decano?
Bueno, me refiero a las personas que lo estudiaron y
analizaron esta
maravilla a veces, ya sea que se trate o no de
una
morfología o si podemos usar
los dos términos simultáneamente o
indistintamente.
probablemente sea uno  de esas cosas
en las que si
quieres averiguar cuáles son los detalles
, probablemente deberías ir y echar un vistazo
porque es interesante, pero no
en este punto, todo lo que básicamente queremos
hacer es
aquí, solo leeré esta
retroducción del  proceso por el cual de
la sorprendente variedad de hechos somos conducidos
a
una conjetura hemos usado mucho
teoría para dar cuenta de ellos muchos
lógicos se niegan a llamar a esta última
inferencia
porque su conclusión es tan extremadamente
problemática que equivale a poco más
que una interrogación
Estoy seguro de que están equivocados, sin embargo,
no se han
apoderado de la verdadera
definición científica de inferencia, por lo que básicamente lo que está
diciendo aquí es que no
llamemos al
razonamiento abductivo infrarrojo um
razonamiento inductivo
la justificación lógica de una
retroducción cuya
conclusión correcta es que el  estado
de cosas conjeturado es probable
en el vago sentido de que tiende
a parecerse al
estado de cosas real y esta es la parte
donde ¿y qué?  en reemplaza ese
instrumentalismo
lo que sea que definamos como
esto es de nuevo
este es uno de esos acertijos si no lo es
si no es
un
estado real es lo que no es entonces lo que es un estado
irreal o no real porque está
ahí
hemos  lo etiquetó como
lo que llena lo que se siente que
eventualmente hacer el todo esa es la
pregunta aquí
y también nuevamente vale la pena leer algunos
de los trabajos previos de uno de los autores
del artículo sobre la abducción y uno puede ver
en su investigación una fuerte línea de
desarrollo y  extendiendo y
modernizando gran parte del trabajo,
digamos,
sí, así que dejé esos letreros de osos
porque quiero contar una historia muy,
muy rápida,
así que si vives en un lugar donde hay
osos si el letrero del oso permanece, la
gente comienza a ignorar el
objeto de signo real
y ya no se convierten en
intérpretes, pierden voluntariamente
esa tríada, por
lo que si está en el negocio del
bienestar animal y no quiere que los osos
se acostumbren demasiado
a hu  hombre contacto tienes que ser
muy selectivo cuando colocas el letrero
y lo más importante cuando quitas el
letrero,
así que quería poner eso allí
porque es una gran parte de la
pieza de abducción y retroducción,
a veces tienes que quitar cosas
para  la abducción para trabajar es la eliminación
de posibilidades lo
que realmente
crea un
énfasis. Creo que continuaremos con el realismo
y el instrumentalismo porque
volveremos a la abducción en las
discusiones posteriores, así que
aquí hay algunas citas de un artículo de Fair Bend.
Según el realismo, dicho conocimiento, el
conocimiento fáctico, es descriptivo de
las características generales o particulares del
universo, por lo que eso no significa que el
modelo de gravedad sea la gravedad, no significa
que el modelo de gravedad sea lo que son los
objetos de gravedad,
pero un realista lo haría.  remarque que, por
ejemplo, los modelos formales de gravedad
nos enseñan la existencia de
objetos sobre los que actúa la fuerza de gravedad
y autorizan la descripción de una fuerza
que puede  no se ve directamente, se escucha o se
siente, pero aún tiene una influencia notable. Las
fuerzas son cosas reales. Son reales
según el instrumentalismo.
Incluso una teoría que es completamente correcta
no describe nada, sino que sirve como
un instrumento para la predicción de los
hechos que constituyen su
contenido empírico,
y así.  Nuevamente, en el
ejemplo de la gravitación de Newton, los instrumentistas
podrían tomar la posición de que no hay
entidades, la
fuerza de la gravitación y los campos gravitatorios
son meras aplicaciones instrumentales
de
argumentos estadísticos o potencialmente incluso argumentos dinámicos sociales o de
poder,
y un instrumentista puede negar la
existencia de objetos,
entidades y fuerzas en este  caso
e incluso llevar las cosas al nivel de
tener escepticismo en torno a las palabras como
instrumentos y las relaciones en torno a la
comunicación
y cómo ordena y predice los datos sensoriales
hemos explorado mucho el realismo y el
instrumentalismo en las
transmisiones y destacamos mucho en el
trabajo de mel andrews  en número de transmisión en vivo  14.
una diapositiva más sobre realismo e
instrumentalismo y luego cualquiera de ustedes
por favor siéntanse libres
um describiré algunas de las últimas
nuevamente la distinción del territorio del mapa es
muy
clave para la conversación sobre realismo e instrumentalismo
también ha habido una variedad de excelentes
trabajos filosóficos
para  ejemplo, un sucesor del realismo,
el antirrealismo cuestiona
esos dos, por cierto, diría que son
negaciones, mientras que el realismo y el
instrumentalismo
que sugerimos podrían verse como
contrarios
y también el trabajo de helen longano sobre
el pluralismo científico tiene mucho que decir al
respecto al tomar una
lente multidisciplinario sobre el realismo y el
instrumentalismo
y luego decano, ¿te gustaría describir
algo sobre este artículo principal que encontraste?
uh,
podría, no recuerdo esto en los
grandes esquemas para ser honesto, está aquí para que la
gente lo lea, había muchos artículos
y  de nuevo, solo estamos poniendo mucho
texto para aquellos que quieren hacer una pausa y
seguir los senderos
y todo se enreda en
stephen an  y comentarios sobre realismo
instrumentalismo supongo que lo que me
viene a la mente mucho es que
todo esto se basa
en la acción en algún nivel, por
lo que
la idea de
buscar diferentes
contradicciones o diferentes enfoques
retro
podría ser un caso  de ustedes imaginan
cuando alguien piensa en tomar un camino a
través del
bosque, saben o podrían volver a encarnar muchas de
estas cosas
o y tal vez todo en algún
nivel pasa por alguna encarnación
um y cuando es conceptual esa
encarnación simplemente está sucediendo en  un
espacio más conceptual
um que no se basa en tantos otros
um
tipos de historias o
sentir tu camino a través de las cosas
así que um
la diferencia que sucede cuando estás
en un campo de práctica es que estás tan
acostumbrado a estar en eso  campo de práctica
que
esa encarnación se convierte en el agua en la
que nadas, por
lo que podría ser
algo que se relacione con este
gran sí, decano, muy rápido, así que
nuevamente preguntaremos en este punto sí para
darnos cuenta  sm
sí al instrumentalismo
sí hasta el final
no o
deshecho
teníamos un pequeño ampersand aquí y nosotros
el y aquí
um una breve nota sobre la cognición electrónica
no profundizaremos aquí pero 4e puede
referirse a xiavio y van der
Schiff 2018 artículo que estaba en el
contexto de la pedagogía musical, que es un
área muy fascinante 4e está incorporado
incrustado incrustado
extendido promulgado
enculturado etc etc etc 7e 11e 22e todos
ellos y luego una cita divertida de carl
fristen
de nuestro
simposio de inferencia activa aplicada en
dijo que una cosa clave sobre la inferencia activa
es que está más allá del
procesamiento predictivo, está más allá de la sensibilidad y
enfatiza o refleja el
giro pragmático a principios de este siglo
realmente personificado por las cuatro e
para dejar en claro que la sensibilidad es
activa
y que estás hablando  sobre
la causalidad circular del compromiso
con cualquier partícula personal o planta con
lo que sea que esté ahí fuera causalidad circular púrpura
y todo eso implica
entonces bastante breve  No vamos a entrar
en ninguno de estos detalles, pero aquí hay un
montón de trabajo que es relevante para el
artículo inactivo,
solo algunas de las otras
citas de antecedentes y otros trabajos que uno podría
querer investigar
y para el artículo abductivo
y también un  un poco de inclinación incluso
en algo, con suerte los autores pueden
revelarnos el papel y la
relación del nominalismo con todo
esto, pero muchos artículos anteriores de los
autores aquí
enumerados y mucho trabajo excelente nuevamente, así que
gracias compañeros por
este viaje
ahora
podemos entrar en los dos papeles o en el
espacio entre
tengamos una yuxtaposición inicial de
los dos papeles pondré nuestro video
será la punta del iceberg aquí así que decano
eres la punta del iceberg qué
te gustaría decir  sobre estos dos documentos
en una yuxtaposición inicial,
bueno, como dije, creo que
si realmente retrocedes y te das cuenta de
que lo que la gente está haciendo
al emparejarse con la inferencia activa
, estás diciendo
que tengo, tengo un tipo particular  de
análisis situacional que me
gustaría realizar y, al hacerlo, me
gustaría tratar de eliminar contradicciones o me
gustaría
formular integraciones
y si retrocedes a ese lugar,
tu ejemplo de entonces tu tu hiper tu
hiper um
tu cabeza tu  el tema es sub uh
análisis situacional su ejemplo
encaja bajo que
ahora no está cometiendo
el error de decir
mi forma de hacerlo mirar las cosas
automáticamente niega o convierte otras
formas de ver todo lo que está
bajo ese título un análisis situacional de la situación
en polvo  ahora
hay comparaciones y no están
escritas aquí y están tan listas
que básicamente elegí ejemplos dentro de
cada uno de los artículos donde los
artículos hablan de dos
puntos focales diferentes pero aún están dentro de
este límite marginal más grande
de activo  inferencia y cómo
la inferencia activa se
está comportando en
torno al comportamiento
dentro de un régimen de atención y
abriéndolo a algo más disponible que
el  los detalles o la escala
amigable de la teoría de la mente necesariamente se
combina
con la inferencia activa
o la idea de que la abducción del momento
en que llego en realidad
niega cualquier posibilidad de usar
instrumentos para extender mi mi
ventana sensorial,
así que nuevamente no vamos a gastar
mucho tiempo
sacando esas otras cosas, pero si las
personas realmente quieren ver cómo cuando
colocas aproximadamente dos papeles uno al lado del
otro puedes encontrar un montón
de similitudes, es un ejercicio interesante,
toma un tiempo,
pero cuando realmente los ves  uno al lado del
otro y enredados hay un
montón de trenzados
gracias dean stephen
sí me gusta esto um
como dean estaba hablando ahí
tienes estos dos papeles casi podrían
verse como dos icebergs donde
sus filosofías son amables  de
congelado y
dado forma y forma y hay cosas
debajo y cosas arriba,
pero también está el agua en el
medio
que puede tener
muchos camarones  y todo tipo de
cosas nadando alrededor, así
que creo que en esta lista aquí donde
tienes una especie de realismo
instrumentalismo, bueno, son tus dos
icebergs, verdad
, queremos que sean agradables y nítidos
y tal vez te golpeen un poco si
golpeas.  fuera de ellos y luego, está bien, estadísticas
y comparación de modelos
,
saben que todavía están ahí afuera,
pero podrían tener un poco
de comunicación de creencias entre múltiples agentes, oh, espera,
tenemos algo que fluye aquí,
cosas como conjuntos ensamblados, lo siento,
modelos como perspectiva de conjuntos.
o perspectiva ajustada o de dónde
provienen esas perspectivas formas de conocer
los sistemas complejos de estocasticidad
y así sucesivamente
um
ahora estamos tal vez
no sé si no estamos disolviendo
el iceberg eso no se trata de que el
iceberg está allí pero estamos  son
diferentes tipos de
maneras y
de comenzar a ser tal vez más flexibles
y menos estables,
increíble, así que en el documento inactivo vamos
para mantener las cosas razonables y también
tenemos mucho que discutir en uno  y dos
nuevamente, pusimos una gran cantidad de contenido en las
diapositivas para que se detenga y disfrute. La
mayor parte del contenido se copia y se cita
del documento, por lo que ese es el punto de
referencia para obtener más información
. Simplemente lo recorreremos
en el orden de la hoja de ruta.  algunas de las
piezas clave por las que pasan los documentos, por lo que
en la sección uno del documento inactivo
van a comenzar con un
resumen
del argumento de vessier at all 2020 para
comprender a los demás en el mundo y
que se presenta en este pensamiento a
través de otras mentes en papel  y luego
tom es la teoría de la
mente resumen
o capturan el argumento de pensar a
través de otras mentes como una
premisa una la cognición social está inactiva
y encarnada dos inactiva y encarnada
el actor social no puede captar directamente
la cognición social
tres cualquier cosa que no pueda captarse directamente
debe ser inferida
ergo qed conclusión se
debe inferir la cognición social inactiva y corporizada
se debe inferir sobre
la cognición social
y los autores de la  papel inactivo
afirma que por la premisa dos y tres
ttom se une a la ortodoxia tom
entender el mundo y los demás a
ellos se reduce a la capacidad de inferir
y atribuir estados mentales
que es el resumen uh de pensar a
través de otras mentes
y que van a poner en cuestión
en esta disección crítica de que tal
cuenta ttom está haciendo que este
matrimonio sea feliz con un activismo del
que van a sacar sí, cualquiera
o continuar, está bien, van
a, van a sacar algunas cosas
diferentes de  estas premisas
y qué suposiciones ocultas podrían estar
subyacentes a esas premisas, como qué
axiomas llevan a uno a generar tales
premisas,
la contradicción entre p1 y p2
resulta de dos suposiciones ocultas en
ese argumento t2m, así que aquí vemos p123
arriba
y luego la suposición oculta que una
cognición social reduce a  información
en forma proposicional explícita
representación mental y
adscripción van a decir esto se
sienten así como un  la representación mental
y la suposición oculta también la
cognición social están conectadas con los conceptos
y las herramientas lógicas para la inferencia, por
ejemplo,
al nacer
y en las secciones posteriores
analizarán y aclararán la
contradicción entre las premisas uno y
dos,
esta tensión de
si la cognición social es  Si es activo y
encarnado, ¿
es realmente el caso o es una
afirmación contradictoria de
que la cognición social no puede ser
captada directamente por un actor social de
este tipo? Luego evaluarán críticamente
desde la perspectiva inactiva qué
problemas podrían subyacer a estos
supuestos, los supuestos ocultos y
por qué.  un activista rechaza estas suposiciones ocultas
y, por lo tanto, rechaza las premisas enumeradas
anteriormente
y luego van a explorar
cuáles son estos
métodos y mecanismos no representativos de
co-construcción en la acción social
tienen una manta markov
una representación visual que hemos
visto aquí antes
con los estados internos estados externos
y la mediación de en  estados internos y
externos por estados generales
que, según la definición de la perla de 1988,
son los estados generales que hacen que los
estados internos y externos sean
condicionalmente independientes.
y esos dos tipos de estados se
definen por su entrada desde la
perspectiva de estados internos
dependencias estadísticas estados sensoriales
y dependencias estadísticas salientes
que pueden interpretarse como acciones o
interfaces de
la entidad o cosa hacia el nicho
pero volveremos a las mantas de markov
y más adelante,
sí, stephen, ve por eso,
solo volviendo a eso, en
realidad, la página de la diapositiva anterior a esto,
pero en relación con esto es cuando dice que las
cosas no pueden ser directamente, hay un
par de cosas que se pueden captar directamente,
yo diría que con
eso eso es un  distinción útil porque
cuando pensamos en um estamos
hablando del agarre y  la empuñadura o un par de
alicates y no puedo sujetar directamente un
tubo caliente necesito los alicates no puedo directamente
um hacer varias cosas sin tal vez
más de una herramienta
pero existe la sensación de que
cuando hablamos de agarrar cosas o
cuando las personas están pensando en si
algo es
, sabes captar algo
que es explícitamente proposicional
, sabes que tenemos otros tipos de herramientas
que podrían entrar en juego, incluso cuando
pensamos en palabras
y el acto de atribuir
todas estas cosas pueden ser
actuaciones con  herramientas en todos los niveles, por
lo que
hay una combinación interesante
aquí, dependiendo de cómo
se derrita el iceberg,
excelente
en la sección dos,
que puede leer en el periódico o hacer una pausa
aquí y capturar muchos aspectos de
él. Van a cuestionar la suposición.
que la cognición social se reduce a la representación mental
y
su punto puede destilarse ya que
comprender a los demás es una cuestión de
ser hábil en significados compartidos no explícitos
y potencialmente algunos
abductivos
ding-ding-ding y el razonamiento basado en modelos,
todos los cuales son
modificables y dinámicos en contextos específicos,
y van a desentrañar en
los párrafos siguientes que ahí radica
una contradicción evidente entre esas
dos primeras premisas, que es realmente como
el talón de Aquiles.  o el punto débil
donde van a enfocar su lógica
en la sección
dos, van a cuestionar ese segundo de
los supuestos, que es que la
cognición social está programada desde el nacimiento
y, por lo tanto, califican la posición final
y dicen que sí.  no tienen una
posición nativista, por ejemplo, como una
perspectiva puramente innata
porque se enfocan en la
dinámica ecológica y de desarrollo de
cómo se adquiere la cultura,
cuestionan
la adquisición del paquete de inicio
y también están explorando más en esta
sección  algunas críticas inactivistas de, por
ejemplo, perspectivas cableadas sobre la cognición social
en la sección 3
que critican suposiciones que en
su mente resaltan  la contradicción
inherente a pensar a través de otras
mentes van a sugerir otra
relación oh, no te gusta ese plato
, probemos este
y este será un
enfoque de la teoría de sistemas dinámicos
o dst escriben
dst
como argumentaremos en  esta sección es un
enfoque que sirve para aprender y
generar poder predictivo sobre las
prácticas socioculturalmente situadas de los
agentes que construyen su nicho
porque dst tiene en su núcleo
herramientas útiles como la emergencia, la
no linealidad y la espontaneidad,
etc., nos permite alejarnos de las
nociones prefabricadas.  de tom teoría de la
mente teorías similares a la cognición social
, por lo tanto, uno debe abstenerse de hacer
suposiciones
ontológicas, aquí ontológicas sobre cómo
son las cosas en el mundo,
por lo que más de la ontología de los filósofos en
lugar del
sentido de la ontología de gestión del conocimiento de las ciencias de la computación
uno debe abstenerse de hacer  este
tipo de supuestos ontológicos
autorizados por el realismo
sobre el complejo  sistema basado en un
modelo manejable,
por lo que el hecho de que el modelo sea tan
manejable
no significa que tengamos la licencia
para hacer suposiciones ontológicas,
ya que el modelo manejable es una
oportunidad para aprender sobre el
comportamiento complejo, solo
se
permiten afirmaciones epistémicas.  mire el reclamo
para hacerlo manejable, podemos representar un
sistema dinámico mediante una relación estática de la
siguiente manera y aquí están
sus ecuaciones uno, dos y tres con
los títulos a continuación
y están usando estos muy
simples como el núcleo de los
sistemas dinámicos  la teoría es
entender cómo las
cosas son una función de cómo cambian en
términos generales y se representa de
diferentes maneras
en términos de un modelo sucesor y más
de un modelo de rayo de cambio
stephen creo que este es un
punto muy útil punto número tres ahí
la viñeta  punto porque también habla
de ese sentido de que
esto es un enfoque de modelado
, veamos qué
nos dice el modelo en lugar de un
ajuste de modelo
enfoque
um, que a menudo es saber lo que termina
sucediendo si tiene la
ontología definida, sabe que
efectivamente muchas cosas, así
que um, esa es quizás una pieza clave
que
vincula mucho sobre cómo se pueden unir las cosas en
términos de inferencia activa y cómo
podría  ser sostenido entre
usted sabe
que es una
es una postura en cierto
modo es mantener las piernas separadas y
decir
está bien, ¿
estoy haciendo las divisiones o tengo las
piernas juntas
bien, así
que averigüémoslo en lugar de que
usted?
y
sí, gracias,
gracias Dean, sí,
solo quería agregar a lo que
Stephen estaba diciendo.
Hasta este punto, realmente y me encanta
el artículo
que es la pieza constructivista,
aunque creo que
me hace
detenerme por un minuto porque creo
que  Para que
podamos
tomar esa decisión, ¿
son las divisiones o es una bifurcación? ¿Es
literalmente una bifurcación? En lugar de tener
que ir de izquierda a derecha, eso requiere una
deconstrucción
que creo que a menudo se deja de lado
antes.  a una reconstrucción,
así que nuevamente no estoy discutiendo con los
autores porque creo que están
respetando la autonomía
y creo que han hecho un trabajo brillante
al decir que está bien, esta lógica, este
camino deductivo que otros autores han tomado
puede no necesariamente aplicarse aquí
porque hace que se mezclen demasiado tan bien bien
bien estás sosteniendo lo que en
realidad es izquierda y derecha,
pero estás omitiendo
agregar y la parte es que podría ser un tenedor
que literalmente podría recoger y el  La única
forma en que puedes ver eso es si puedes
deconstruir
antes de reconstruir y deconstruir
no significa diferenciar eso
ya está presente deconstruir literalmente
significa como
la unidad ¿
cuándo llegué en este momento? ¿qué
tengo qué partes del rompecabezas
todavía me faltan?  porque
tengo prisa por averiguar si se
supone que debo ir a la izquierda o a la derecha a continuación,
especialmente en el contexto total, especialmente
allí,
sí, Stephen, si desea dar un
punto rápido aquí, gracias, simplemente agrego a
eso um
esa parte de la situacionalidad,
um,
creo que ahí es donde entras en la
conciencia de lo que está pasando, así que la ciencia
nos está diciendo mucho qué está pasando,
qué es esa cosa, qué es
esto, qué es eso,
pero esa bifurcación en el camino o ser tú
sabes un  equipo, equipo, unión de edad o
algo más, en
última instancia, hay una pieza de conciencia
dónde se encuentra eso y en
inferencia activa que a menudo es más
compleja, nebulosa
con el ser científico sobre la
precisión
del método, bueno,
otras veces la conciencia y la
complejidad vienen en la inferencia activa puede
tener ambos  esos, sí, geniales,
continuando con las últimas partes del
artículo, hablan mucho sobre la complejidad, que a
muchos de nosotros nos encanta,
complejidad, complejidad, ciencia,
teoría de la complejidad, trae tantos
términos geniales, conceptos, personas, métodos, herramientas,
ideas, todo
y hablan mucho sobre autopolíticas
y esta recursividad.  por lo tanto, hay muchos
vínculos de vinculación realmente creativos
en el documento inactivo y la complejidad es
utilizados de una manera realmente valiosa
en la sección
cuatro, pasarán a la
inferencia activa en un entorno dinámico inactivo
y ahí es donde la inferencia activa
se implementará como un
instrumento perspicaz para aprender y comprender
las dinámicas que subyacen a las
co-construcciones culturales.
teniendo en cuenta que no necesariamente toma a los
agentes como agentes pasivos
, juntos son los autores de los
estados de los demás
y, por lo tanto, es
algo análogo a las
figuras inactivas que se muestran anteriormente, donde teníamos los
engranajes en la cabeza
y luego me gustó que los engranajes
estuvieran más distribuidos.  en el cuerpo y
en la mente
aquí en la figura 2 hay más un
significado clásico y un razonamiento basado en modelos donde
diferentes actores sociales tienen una especie
de cuenta inferencial que es
muy parecida a una direccional como se muestra aquí
con una flecha apuntando justo al
medio y  en la figura 3 están representando
la acción social en la figura 2 bajo
inferencia activa en términos de etiquetar
aquí
los estados internos  del actor social
y los estados externos siendo el
actor social uno, así que esto es desde la
perspectiva del actor social dos,
donde los estados generales se
enmarcan como significado sociocultural y ese
razonamiento basado en modelos
que se abre a cuentas inferenciales
que se distribuyen
y promulgan
y
[Música] con
suerte entraremos en más detalles
porque aquí es donde están
apoyando su
aplicación instrumentalista positiva de
inferencia activa en el espacio social inactivo
y luego escriben caracterizando una
escena social como análoga a la práctica científica
está ahí por una caracterización errónea es
casi  como tomar lo que sucede en el
laboratorio en un contexto determinado e incluso
una cierta visión de lo que sucede en el
laboratorio en un contexto determinado
coma en un contexto determinado
y luego criticar eso
y pensar un poco más ampliamente
sobre lo que sucede en los pasillos
del laboratorio  y en el sótano y
en el mundo alrededor del edificio
y eso también es r  muy bien conectado
con algún bronberg amarillo en absoluto el trabajo sobre
el cerebro que anticipa no es un
científico que también se enfoca en la
perspectiva inactiva desde una
perspectiva ecológica no solo necesariamente lo
social sino que lo social es un caso importante
en la tabla 1
que van a discutir  un poco
más sobre
algunos de los divisores y contenidos de las
celdas relacionadas con el mundo natural y
las herramientas y construcciones científicas,
seguramente volveremos aquí en
discusiones posteriores, así que simplemente consulte la
tabla uno para
ver qué piensa,
qué otras líneas le gustaría  dibujar,
serían como líneas curvas
como si fueran letras, rodearías
cualquier cosa, dibujarías algunos triángulos
, agregarías otra fila, lo
convertirías en un tensor, qué más dibujarías en la
tabla uno,
incluso si solo otra
línea de doble límite para enfatizar  que es perfecto como lo
es Dean,
todo lo que diría es que si va y
echa un vistazo a esto, pregúntese por qué estos
hiperparámetros y por qué llegan
tarde  rals
porque creo que
eso conducirá a todo tipo de
cosas buenas para mí, me tiene tan retorcido,
divertido,
está bien, y luego la conclusión antes de pasar
al segundo artículo
, hemos demostrado que mantener tanto el
activismo como la teoría de la mente implica
contradicción y  confusión
esto es evidente cuando analizamos críticamente
las dos suposiciones ocultas sostenidas
por tom, como teorías como ttom, que
son rechazadas por el inactivismo, esas dos
suposiciones encubiertas que creen
desacreditan el vínculo
y
luego reiteran la naturaleza co-constructiva
y los componentes integrados y ecológicos.
de la inacción social
y la recurrencia y el despliegue a
través del tiempo del despliegue de la inacción social
y sugieren que la
teoría de sistemas dinámicos
y la inferencia activa
aplicada instrumentalmente como un tipo de modelado de sistemas dinámicos
es prometedora
y es una herramienta adecuada y complementaria
para considerar la comprensión social como
sincronización generalizada
celebrada de cierta manera
por lo que fue que p  aper
y ahora se combinará
con el documento abductivo, así que
una respiración antes de pasar a la abducción,
sí, stephen
tomando ese aliento, um, esa última
oración sobre cómo puede ser,
um, casi un puente, son el
uso complementario, um, de la teoría de sistemas dinámicos.
y en cierto modo llena un vacío, están
llenando un vacío y, en cierto modo, creo que mientras
hablamos sobre el documento de abducción, algunos
de los vacíos que no llenan,
sé que no estamos tratando de hablar sobre
llenar vacíos aquí, pero  digamos que está
llenando vacíos, la
abducción
también podría sentirse, así que conoce
la belleza de la belleza de la
inferencia activa y el enfoque bayesiano es
que hay muchas
escalas y modalidades diferentes y se pueden
ponderar y combinar para darle,
um, potencialmente una idea
de lo que  hacer lo correcto para
que no signifique que uno excluya al otro
increíble
bien
inter
abducción obtusamos lejos
el documento comienza con una introducción relativamente
corta y muy
concisa a algunos de los puntos clave
del documento
que describimos anteriormente  r en sus objetivos
que están interesados en esta inter
retación naturalista de al
unos de los trabajos posteriores de cs pierce, por e
emplo, posteriores a 1903 o posteriores a 1905, en su ma
oría trabajos inéditos que desen
rañan las nociones semióticas y lógicas del r
zonamiento abductivo que cubri
os en la sección de conte
to.  modelo biológico
de abducción
que va a
enhebrar la aguja
tejer la tela lo que sea
que mantenga la integridad funcional
del organismo
el imperativo evolutivo para
la existencia de ese ser vivo y para que sea
compatible con la neurociencia moderna
se centran en la lealtad y la
alianza que nos  mencionado anteriormente
y también presentarán en la
introducción el concepto de manta de Markov,
que será un excelente punto de
yuxtaposición para agregar un poco más de
detalle, como si fuera un frente, un
frente de contacto con inferencia activa con
inacción social y abducción,
entonces estos  son como puntos calientes o puntos
de contacto dentro del frente de la interfaz para
acercar realmente el zoom, ¿de acuerdo?  Este
estado interno se usa en estos dos modelos y
ahí es donde la
ontología de inferencia activa es de inmenso valor porque
incluso cuando las personas hablan en
diferentes idiomas o tenemos un
programa de computadora, una ecuación, un poema y
luego un artículo científico,
cuando podemos vincular y proactivamente  usar o
anotar de manera proactiva con la
ontología de inferencia activa,
ganamos la capacidad de no solo decir bueno
, ambos estamos señalando la luna
es tu dedo mi dedo o estamos
señalando el mismo dedo porque está
muy lejos y tal vez sea un poco
mordió y a su rayo le falta la
luna desde mi punto de vista,
y así sucesivamente, en cambio, podemos
bajar y no
desangrarnos en la mesa de operaciones,
sino fijar transitoriamente y encontrar
un atractor que nos ayude realmente a entrar en
esa intersección.  que simplemente
golpear y correr con solo puntos de
resonancia decano,
sí,
nuevamente, solo resumiré eso diciendo que
podemos analizar mejor la situación
porque ahora en realidad h  Tengo
una forma de poder mantener algo en
común,
así que eso es todo lo que quiero agregar a lo que
acabas de decir
y solo agregar uno a eso también
es sí, lo siento, pero um,
y donde puede haber
una diferencia, así
que ya sabes.
podría haber esta comprensión de
muchos de los términos la
comprensión ontológica y decir
lo que a menudo es un problema si hay
algo que no está
alineado pero
simplemente no se nota o se pasa por alto decir
está bien esto es diferente está bien hay un
cambio ontológico aquí
hay un  De alguna manera, hay una
manera de que sea manejable
como lo tenemos con la inferencia activa. Es
una forma manejable de hacerlo porque, de lo
contrario, hay tantas
cosas ontológicas flotando en este espacio,
que es su belleza,
que no es cognitivamente
posible encontrar lo que buscas.  necesito mirar
gracias
la siguiente sección
nuevamente con estas dos luces
co-iluminando co-
construyendo dos luces no pueden superponerse físicamente por lo
que debe haber paralaje inducido  por estas
dos luces y sombras y todo tipo de
efectos y tal vez no sea la misma
longitud de onda y tal vez estés
caminando y diferentes lados tengan
diferentes iluminaciones
la sección está en la inferencia activa a
la luz de la abducción
esta
es una
sección muy fascinante
porque  Vamos a tomar ese
marco casi casi algorítmico pero ciertamente precomputacional que
se desarrolló a fines del siglo XIX
y principios del XX
y comenzaremos a
interactuar y ver
cómo se relaciona con la inferencia activa
para que podamos resaltar más y
esperamos discutir en  más
secciones, así que haga una pausa si quiere
leer todo esto o leer el documento,
pero se están enfocando en el último esquema.
la iluminación en realidad está tratando de
hablar sobre eso, tal vez, tal vez
, no sé si realmente tenía los
formalismos para respaldar eso,
pero la inferencia activa en realidad ahora
habla un  sobre el tipo de
nivel de energía
que ahora podemos
ver dentro de las dos
restricciones que esa esa idea de
parametrizar de nuevo al tipo de agarre del vicio
gracias, así que solo algunas citas que son
realmente fascinantes aquí,
así que
en abducción científica  se puede comparar con
la lógica del descubrimiento de hipótesis
que, como discutimos anteriormente, tiene un
elemento creativo generativo y luego un
componente selectivo secundario, como
la selección del modelo bayesiano, la reducción del modelo bayesiano
e incluso agregan una advertencia de
que no
puede ocurrir una asimilación completa de la abducción de Pearson.
a ibe eso es inferencia a la
mejor explicación que es la mitad del
motor de dos tiempos y comúnmente la
gente usará abducción para referirse al
razonamiento probabilístico de un conjunto dado
como abducción en otras partes de los escritos
este esquema posterior
aquellos que son posteriores a 1903
pero
según  para los expertos han sido los menos
investigados que
hay comenzando con una observación de
sorprendente factor e  desahoga la
sorpresa de la observación
y a través de una premisa mayor condicional
concluye en un estado de ánimo co-hortativo de nuevo un
estado de ánimo
que Piers denominó el
investigador es como lo ha hecho y justo en él
y es que algo de
importancia imperativa debe hacerse
pragmatismo inacción selección de políticas
despertado inicialmente  por curiosidad
reducción de la incertidumbre entropía
que conduce a la formulación de una
pregunta
que es semántica
y
hay más discusión sobre el
estado de ánimo investigado y otros estados de ánimo
sí decano otra cosa rápida
agrupada o coconstruida a partir del
otro papel nuevamente
compartimos un prefijo común que
nuevamente  Creo que tal vez pueda
adelantar un
poco más sobre
la importancia de eso en las próximas
transmisiones en vivo.
Increíble, continuarán con esta
cuestión de la economía de la investigación,
por lo
que formaron tres cursos argumentativos que
realmente especificaron áreas de contacto con
inferencia activa.  y abducción
que proponen formar un trío
o tríada inicial
que protagonizarán  t para formar la lealtad
entre la inferencia activa y abductiva
primero la presencia de
relaciones triádicas no degenerativas
luego la utilización de los
principios rectores del razonamiento abductivo
b y tercero la formulación condicional subjuntiva
hay algunos tecnicismos lógicos
arrojados por ahí, pero para
eso están las corrientes
en el punto a en el
que puede hacer una pausa y leer el texto
de van a resaltar el
concepto de manta de markov
o más bien
su
interpretación realista como primera y mantas
y
argumentar
que
las mantas de markov nuevamente implementadas en
un sentido realista primero y general
tienen una marcada penetración
forma triádica irreducible que se
centra en el límite como mediador
entre los estados internos externos y,
por lo tanto, la terceridad que surge en la
semiosis,
hay mucho más que decir, pero si alguno
de ustedes quiere dar un punto más sobre a
está bien en
b van a continuar por  hablando
de algunos de los principios rectores de la
inferencia
y discutiendo específicamente ab  el
papel de la inferencia en la orientación de la inferencia
cuál es el principio rector de las
inferencias activas entonces
aquí van a describir algunos
detalles técnicos de la inferencia activa en
términos de energía libre variacional o
esperada como sorpresa límite
y luego lo conectarán con algunos de
los principales  fuentes de perforación y
discusiones de biosemiótica que
también se han conectado en muchas
discusiones que hemos tenido sobre
representación y significado, etc.,
y va aún más lejos o más lejos
con discusiones sobre
sinequismo
, así como esta
cuestión de la mente universal que  es
forzar el envejecimiento de alguna manera la
cognición universal pan dinámica
cognitiva sistemas cognitivos distribuidos la
materia es la mente decadente de von schiller
y luego van a discutir sobre
mantas prístinas y su construcción
en términos de relaciones triádicas
tríada de pearson objeto de signo interpretante hormiga
lleva a inexplorado
posibilidades
semánticas que reúnen algunos de estos
hilos cualitativos más amplios i  n análisis semiótico
con teoría de sistemas potencialmente dinámicos
métodos bayesianos cuantitativos y
todo lo demás que
trae la inferencia activa junto con los juegos de herramientas para
implementar
y ver
que también están en c voy a desentrañar algunos
elementos constructivos lógicos extremadamente interesantes aunque matizados
de
la proposición semiótica
si pudiera  llámelo
así para profundizar más
en discusiones posteriores,
pero van a explorar
cómo los diferentes
marcos de relaciones lógicas
entre cláusulas o afirmaciones y
garantías y toda esta retórica se
relacionan con el
realismo, la
abducción
y
la versión perforante del realismo como lo
posible es lo que puede volverse real.
sí, hay cosas que son posibles
pero que no pueden volverse reales y luego
qué usamos para ese posible adyacente o
realizable
y
dónde querríamos usarlo y qué
va a romper esa simetría dónde está el
pragmatismo bueno lo que sería útil
considerar sería  el espacio de todos los
posibles que podrían pasar y ninguno
otro y n  No se sorprenda con las
posibilidades adyacentes que no consideramos pero
que sucedieron
y entonces tal vez no sea tan malo gastar
un poco más de pensamiento o algunos
recursos informáticos adicionales para considerar
posibilidades que no podrían suceder
pero que no querríamos.  perdernos en el
espacio potencialmente exponencial de
posibilidades que no pueden suceder
y terminar perdiendo nuestro enfoque y
atención en las posibilidades que pueden
suceder, que son las que pierce describe
como posibilidades reales
y la postura
y el estado de ánimo pragmáticos
también cierran el ciclo con la
selección de políticas y  pragmatismo en inferencia activa
donde dicen que el
significado pragmatista de las creencias en la formulación de bane paris
es que sobre uno sobre el cual uno es
capaz de actuar
y hay muchas resonancias allí
stephen
sí, creo que esto también habla entonces de
la necesidad de tener
hablamos de escala amigable o niveles
o conoce algún tipo de estructura que permite que
esto esté presente
porque sabe que la influencia activa puede así  rt de ir
todo el camino hacia abajo y llevado hasta
el nivel celular, ya que hay formas de
verlo
aquí, hay una sensación de que está bien, estamos
viendo
estas um
ideas de um un significante
pero sabemos con inferencia activa que
no es eso  cree que tenemos
señales entrantes que se procesan
y agregan,
por lo que hay una especie de escala en la
que tienes las estructuras en las que
tienes la
morfogénesis tal vez para llegar a
una escala para hacer que
la señal de alto tenga sentido
para
interpretarse como su  propio
significante, así que creo que puede ser
donde va a ocurrir esta tensión
entre los inactivistas aquí y
dónde puede suceder, pero el argumento
bien podría, diría, es que ciertas
escalas,
ciertas estructuras
y tal vez ciertas
formas realistas de que sucedan las cosas,
algo así como  eso
es factible,
genial, solo dean y luego avanzaremos rápidamente
por el resto, déjame ser
muy rápido aquí, creo que especialmente en b
y y hasta en menor medida y c
el autobús  La forma en que tomamos los piercings, el
pensamiento penetrante
en el ámbito de la inferencia activa
se basa en una suposición y es
que la continuación de nuestra
existencia continua nuestra
realidad continua um
significa que estamos acumulando más
experiencias con las herramientas
en el mundo las reglas en el  el mundo y
las piscinas y por piscinas me refiero a esas
agregaciones que Stephen estaba
señalando para agradecerte por mencionar
eso steven porque eso me hizo querer
escribir esto agregaciones como
densidades
historia de dos densidades que se materializan
así que de nuevo no sé
que tú
decir exclusivamente que todo es real y
luego todos los ejemplos debajo también son
reales porque incluso el mismo perforar
dijo que hay un aspecto de esta
realidad que
nunca podremos describir como otra cosa
que
no sea la realidad
a pesar de que estamos usando fundamentalmente
entonces, ¿cómo es eso,
cómo permite eso
que se formen estas densidades y
sé que suena
muy mal y se fue, lo siento pero es  en realidad, algo que
tenemos que contemplar,
gracias, luego
cambiarán el guión o al menos la sintaxis
y hablarán sobre la abducción a la luz de
la inferencia activa.
Aquí es donde comienzan con ese
reconocimiento del motor de dos tiempos
con abducción generativa y  abducción selectiva
y luego van a conectar eso
con parte de la ontología de la
inferencia activa en términos de ver
la abducción selectiva
como un
proceso de muestreo
y comprender dónde
encaja la abducción generativa
para continuar viendo la abducción
a la luz de la inferencia activa que
incluso podríamos operacionalizar diciendo como
enmarcar o ver la abducción
desde la perspectiva de la ontología de inferencia activa, de
modo que en lugar de que nos
auto-elegamos
como interpretación de la inferencia activa como
un
concepto que no necesariamente podemos
hablar por un concepto
que no podemos hablar en inglés pero  podemos
usar palabras en inglés
y, por lo tanto, de manera análoga, no necesitamos
necesariamente hablar por infe activo  Ahora,
aunque soy el último en decir lo que
deberían o no deberían
hacer, es posible
usar la ontología de inferencia activa y
luego es como una
lista de verificación de dos pasos,
fue el término en el acto de la ontología de inferencia
en el suplemento central o
secciones implicadas
se usó
de una manera pragmática que tenía
sentido en esa situación
en ese contexto de múltiples escalas
y que en realidad es un proceso de dos pasos
para preguntar si estamos hablando
usando inferencia activa en lugar de si
estamos hablando por  como un defensor o
como un vendedor de inferencia activa
per se
y van a reafirmar el caso en
términos del marco fap en el sentido
de y usando los términos de
y van a resaltar la
relación de los estados internos
con los externos  estados mediados a través de la
manta
y luego pasan por este silogismo
y reestructuran y reafirman su
esquema cualitativo de inferencia activa abductiva
y describen este
ciclo de percepción de cognición de acción
donde surge un  risal se experimenta cualquier
información sensorial entrante
y luego la
toman no solo como
una interpretación pasiva o incluso activa de ella
en el contexto de un modelo generativo bayesiano
,
sino como algo que se está desarrollando
en ese estado de ánimo del investigador
que continúan
y traen  uh, importante idea penetrante
de la economía de la investigación,
así que volveremos a repasar esto, con suerte,
con los autores.
um, se relaciona con la teoría de la
ciencia
de pierce.
entre la utilidad
y el costo
y, específicamente, eso se
relacionará con la investigación en este
sentido pragmático socialmente promulgado
al preguntar cómo, dado el gasto de dinero,
tiempo y energía,
qué
se obtendrá la adición más valiosa
al conocimiento,
qué experimento que mis ojos podrían
desear.  tener la mayor cantidad de información
ganar
qué experimentos podría
llevar a cabo el investigador para reducir su incertidumbre  Es
mucho más sobre el sistema natural
no solo para verificar algo que saben
no solo para falsificar algo
que saben que será falsificado sino más bien
para existir en este espacio óptimo de experimentación
y luego perforar y luego los
autores van a naturalizar contextualizar
traer a lo social  área cognitiva
al preguntar bien cómo sucede el dinero, el tiempo y la
energía porque ese
experimento óptimo está en cultivo y usa
energía, usa reactivos, así que quizás de
esta manera podríamos decir que pierce fue
uno de los primeros administradores de programas modernos
para una importante agencia de financiación, pero  no, no lo
era y discutieron
un poco más sobre esta economía de la investigación.
Describen en esta sección
cómo perforar
promueve varios
valores, virtudes o cualidades
que caracterizan la economía de
la elaboración de hipótesis científicas
en complejidad,
que es como una amplitud de reducción de
riesgos
que habla de  la unificación
y la cautela
como la cualidad económica de evitar
rendimientos marginales
decrecientes rompiendo hábilmente  descomponga las preguntas
en una serie de preguntas pequeñas que
se pueden responder con límites razonables
de inversión
cuántos hilos interesantes se
están reuniendo,
por ejemplo, preguntas que se
dividen en preguntas binarias de sí, no, también
se pueden conectar a la teoría de la información
y cuántica
aquí dean  dejaré que
hablen con
justicia, solo lo leeré para ser justos y tan
brevemente al principio de este documento
no hay
interpretaciones instrumentistas de fep y sus
ingredientes, como las mantas de markov,
pero
esta es una nota al pie de página en este documento, pero nuestra
fe  por una palabra mejor y las
credenciales realistas de la fep como sus raíces
en el pragma optimismo pragmatista o
más bien su acto de ameliarismo sobre las
ganancias de la alianza entre
procesos evolutivos evolutivamente útiles para contribuir a maximizar la
supervivencia
si este enfoque pragmático del realismo
desagrada a los elevados  gusto de quien
busca algún criterio metafísico acérrimo
deja mil
flores bl  oom, creo que lo que es fascinante
de esto es
que sostener la idea de que existe un realismo
es una posición muy fácilmente defendible,
pero incluso en la diapositiva anterior, una
de las cosas de las que se
habló por primera vez sin decirlas
directamente o al menos no en  esas citas
fue que
esa posición óptima es algún
elemento de explotación o economía
o simplicidad o alguien ha hecho esto
antes que yo
es que un atajo
y exploración que tiende a tomar
más tiempo tiene más
ensayo y error
pero tampoco te tiene constantemente
sobreajustado
a un resultado particular
así
que um esa es la realidad
y de nuevo no lo haría no
rechazaría la afirmación de que hay una pieza muy
real
en este
juego
jugar un mínimo de dos yendo y
viniendo en este
um
así
que estoy  no solo de hecho estoy completamente de acuerdo con
estos autores como estoy completamente de acuerdo con
los otros autores
sobre la idea de una co-construcción, así
que no sé si
tú estás necesariamente um confundido si
puedes decir sí y sí y sí de nuevo,
steven,
sí, como para agregar a lo que se dice
allí y definitivamente se alude a
la idea de
implementación o
explotación
y en la
ciencia, la
experimentación es una especie de forma de
obtener conocimiento,
pero está la pieza de exploración y
Yo diría que
no se puede obtener la
exploración per se dentro
del tipo de
dominio objetivo que tiene que haber este
viaje a lo
subjetivo performativo a lo subjetivo
liminal
como lo hizo Einstein con sus juegos mentales, todos
estos y tú creas este tipo  de
construcciones mentales de alguna manera, algo
de lo que está sucediendo hoy es una mezcla
de eso y luego eso se trae de vuelta
y se modela, se experimenta con lo que sea,
así que creo que hay un, quiero decir, el modelado es
interesante
porque es, eh, como que puede venir en ese
viaje un  un poco también,
así que
eso podría ser algo que los
experimentos no pueden hacer.
Aquí hay un resumen de una vieja broma: una persona
dice una
y el ref.  eree dice que tienes razón persona
b dice b el árbitro dice que tienes razón
y la persona c dice bueno a y b no pueden tener
razón y el árbitro dice que sabes
que tienes
razón es un poco de humor rápido para los que les
gusta eso  género
um, luego tienen una sección de conclusión
y
tenemos muchas preguntas y puntos que
hacer y muchas conexiones para traer de
vuelta
a gran parte de la naturalización aquí,
como los campos en el
trabajo de levin e incluso lo llevan a las
capacidades regenerativas de platelmintos así que
desde
gusanos planos hasta compañeros de piso,
ahí es donde vamos hoy
y luego también guardamos para el punto
uno
algo de la yuxtaposición del concepto de la
manta de markov, específicamente
los componentes sociales y activos de la
ciencia que son súper importantes y
majeed ha traído a estos
Las discusiones previas son un gran punto
de contacto con el papel abductivo y
las
mantas markov de papel social inactivo representan como un
frente de contacto incluso técnico muy limitado que proporcionará mucha
discusión.  ion en el punto uno
y ahí es
donde cerramos el punto cero
con, de
nuevo, mucho trabajo de base excelente y
empaque de mochila
por parte de dean y steven,
¿hay algo más que le gustaría agregar
en este punto o algo que surja
que quiera discutir?  en el punto uno, sí,
dean, entonces stephen, si quieres que daniel haga un
trabajo fantástico, acabamos de hacer un orden de
magnitud 3 de lo que normalmente era una
transmisión en vivo de un solo papel y todavía lo
recibimos en menos de dos horas para
que estés  ser aplaudido por eso y, en
segundo lugar, solo
quiero, tal vez, como un pequeño consejo para el
punto uno, hay una investigación con el nombre
de israel israel nunez que habla sobre
si quieres poder
ver cómo se deconstruyen las cosas  y
construido, tiene que mirar tanto el
producto en proceso, por ejemplo, ¿
cómo construyo un automóvil
y el proceso en el producto?
¿Qué
es lo que es un
punto de ramificación o un utensilio real?
tanto esa inversión a lo
largo de eso
continuo, abre todo tipo de posibilidades
en términos de llevar las cosas a un lugar
donde no necesariamente entren en
conflicto, sí, pueden integrarse en la trenza
y tal vez eso sea
después de hoy
algo que las personas que están usando
inferencia activa que en mi  la opinión es a la
vez producto y proceso y proceso y
producto
al mismo tiempo es el agarrador y
el agarrador tal vez ellos tal
vez piensen un poco sobre
ellos es casi como si el pragmático viera la
bifurcación en el camino y la usara
y tal vez usted  use el tenedor yendo en una
dirección y tal vez lo recoja, tal vez
lo use completando la disposición de la
mesa para otra persona que cenará
allí y, por lo tanto, hay muchas formas de usarlo
porque el uso es
socialmente promulgado abductivo
contextualizado, etc.
y nuevamente en el  la bifurcación
es donde se lleva a cabo esa conversación
y en nuestro sitio de campo o en el campamento base es
donde podemos imaginar las bifurcaciones y los
caminos que se cruzarán con stephen,
sí, y luego en el en el  punto uno,
encontrar una manera de
traer a los autores si conoce a quienquiera que esté
allí en un pequeño viaje, tal vez por
una de las bifurcaciones, tal vez llegue al
borde del lago y necesitamos entrar
y mojarnos un poco,
¿cómo?  ¿Puede la
abducción científica o algún tipo de modelo más
científicamente delimitado?
Reglas fundamentadas en la
experimentación y la instrumentación. De acuerdo, ¿
cuándo?
¿Cuándo se aleja eso? Tal vez
debido a la participación.
Tal vez debido a la transdisciplinariedad.
Me pregunto si esto es
algo en lo que tal vez quieras pensar
cómo podemos
dar
algún tipo de
opciones de viaje claras para que puedan
salir
un poco sin quedar atrapados
en arenas movedizas o
ahogarse en aguas profundas, ¿
verdad?  así que queremos navegar,
pero creo que esto se le da
algunos de esos um punteros, pienso en
dónde hay una
especie de
rampas de salida de Waze, así como  rampas de acceso, así que
gracias,
esto fue enorme, realmente aprecio
toda su ayuda,
buenos momentos, nos vemos en la muñeca, uno